nous voici à thomson est l'une des
villes les plus criminalisés au pays
cette bourgade du nord du manitoba
occupe le premier rang en matière
d'agression et d'homicide
il ya toujours quelque chose qui se
passe à chaque jour même toronto
montréal et vancouver se retrouve bien
loin derrière thomson les personnes qui
ont causé ces cris menaces sont en état
d'ébriété à rouen caen se met de
l'alcool ou de la drogue pour endiguer
ce flot de criminalité la grc demande
l'aide des organismes locaux dont la
fondation manitobaine de lutte contre
les dépendances
cette communauté compte de nombreux sans
abri nous pouvons les aider et les
accueillir mais la réalité est qu'il
retourne à l'itinérance
ce n'est pas une solution une opinion
partagée par la député fédéral de la
région
niki ashton ya des organismes et des
services dans la communauté absolument
essentiel ici à 30 seul mais il n'y en a
pas assez
keynes autres résidents de thomson
raconte ne pas avoir reçu l'aide dont
ils avaient besoin
ou même très moyen d'action pour payer
ma drogue j'ai commencé à me lancer dans
le crime organisé et a travaillé comme
homme de main pour des trafiquants de
drogue
clint s'en est sorti seul par une prise
de conscience lorsque son frère
toxicomane a failli mourir
toutefois il ne croit pas qu'il est si
facile aujourd'hui de se libérer de la
drogue et de l'alcool
surtout pour les jeunes de thomson il
reste de l'espoir des initiatives
locales font leur apparition au sein de
la communauté
vous voyez les jeunes de sos c'est une
équipe d'intervention formé d'étudiants
et de membres du personnel de l'école
secondaire de thomson
chaque année autour du mois de novembre
les élèves écrivent des commentaires
positifs les uns sur les autres
juste avant les vacances de noël le
groupe placé commentaires sur des pommes
de pin qu'il distribue à chaque élève
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
formons ce groupe
nous disons à tout le monde qu'ils sont
les bienvenus ici
c'est en rehaussant l'estiment personnel
de ces jeunes que l'organisme espère
leur éviter de tomber dans le piège de
la dépendance ici samuel rancourt
radio-canada à thompson